cómo afronta la comunidad de islámica la
comunidad musulmana estos hechos cuál
debería ser la lucha ahora de los
musulmanes para
para que su imágenes sea respetada y
para que no sean satanizados solamente
por su credo creo quienes obviamente
tenemos una gran responsabilidad para
distanciarnos de estos grupos
terroristas fundamentalistas que quieren
usar quieren manchar el nombre del islam
y creo que ahí tenemos una gran
responsabilidad de destacar y recalcar
el mensaje que esos grupos son grupos
militares que
surgieron en un contexto incluso ahora
si tomamos talibanes que surgieron en el
contexto de la guerra fría
en aquel momento incluso recibieron
apoyo económico militar por eeuu para
luchar contra la invasión soviética
entonces hay que entender que esos
grupos tienen intereses geopolíticos
tienen su propia ideología sus propias
tradiciones culturales si tienen sus
propias normas que en muchos casos
contradicen a las enseñanzas del islam
el bloque es obviamente lo más
desafiante para nosotros que ellos usan
en nombre del islam si por ejemplo ahora
en la matanza el terrorismo s13 entre el
islam incluso él obviamente tiene
fuentes entonces para definir un acto
como algo islámico hay que analizarlo
desde la mirada desde la perspectiva de
las enseñanzas islámicas por ejemplo
muchas veces el nombre o la terminología
yihad sí que es muchas veces percibido
como un sinónimo de la guerra santa
contra los no musulmanes pero yihad
desde nuestras fuentes religiosas no
significa guerra significa en árabe
literalmente un esfuerzo noble es decir
un esfuerzo una lucha noble contra tu
propia maldad contra tus propias
agresiones contra tus propios malos
pensamientos es decir por ejemplo no
insultar a nadie no lastimar a nadie
rezar cinco veces si fortalece tu
espiritual ese es el yihad de un
musulmán también por ejemplo otra
palabra muchas veces muy mal entendido
en accidente a la uac ver si muchas
veces usado como un sinónimo para actos
terroristas aunque la uac ver que
existía esta expresión o esa palabra
hace 14 siglos y nunca en el pasado oa
lo largo de la historia
fue usada para atacar a personas
inocentes sino que es una palabra una
expresión para glorificar la unidad de
dios de ala y ala es dios universal no
solamente dios de los musulmanes y el
musulmán o un musulmán cree o sostiene
la postura la doctrina amar a dios a
través de amar y cuidar y servir a toda
su creación entonces un musulmán creo
que ahí tenemos el desafío y también la
responsable especialmente en el
occidente donde convivimos con los no
musulmanes recalcar que esos grupos no
representan nuestros valores no
representan nuestra religión
muchísimas gracias a ustedes y marc
manga willy y yo solamente para cerrar
este espacio con usted quisiera hacerle
una última pregunta dónde estaba usted
el 11 de septiembre del 2001
yo estaba en tal momento en alemania soy
alemán y en ese momento industria yo
volví de la escuela y ahí vi las
imágenes en la televisión y como ya dije
que realmente fue incluso para mí en ese
momento en la escuela fue un antes y un
después del 11 de septiembre de 2001
porque ya poco pocos semanas después
empezaron todas las preguntas e incluso
en esto no entro yo como adolescente en
la escuela y me pidieron explicaciones
sobre talibán yihadistas islamistas
islamismo que yo nunca había leído nada
en nuestras fuentes religiosas entonces
fue realmente para mí también muy fuerte
vivir parecía tan lejano si el 11 de
septiembre algo ocurrió en eeuu pero no
es tan lejano sino que fue realmente es
algo muy personal para cada musulmán que
vive en occidente